blue jays taking on the red sox again
ronda reniki's socks came back and beat
the j's nine to seven last night
this is the third game first start for
julian meriwether in his young major
league career he's 28 years old he had
tommy john surgery in 2018
and a swing and a miss and a ball way up
and out of the zone merriweather strikes
him out
well you don't need any defense for a
strikeout
and a swing and a miss foul tip actually
but back to back strikeouts for
meriwether off to
a great start
martinez with a flyable to left field
out in front of the changeup
and right there is goriel and what a
nice first inning for julie and
merriweather
randall brichik steps in richard drives
the ball to deep
left field and it's gone
what a shot on a 3-2 pitch number eight
on the season for gritchik in the blue
jays lead
brandon bridzick has really taken off
he hit his first home run on the 14th of
august and he has been
dialed in this is the 22nd home run the
blue jays have hit here at salem field
they have out homered their opponents
22-9
and this has become a favorite ballpark
for the blue jays
and then a fastball by him at 97 for
another strikeout
yeah when you have 97.98 we've seen 99
tonight
i think you have to utilize that as your
put away pitch
and you can see moreland's a day late
with that one
after seeing that 80 mile an hour change
up and he
ratchets is up to 97. it's tough for any
hitter to catch up
and a weak ground ball out to second
this should do it in the inning and it
does
a terrific performance by julian
merryweather whether you wanted to call
him a starter or an opener whatever the
case was
he was great one nothing blue chase
bottom of the second here's rowdy teles
teles sends a drive to deep right center
and it's another home run for the blue
jays
richigan the first rowdy in the second
two to nothing blue jays might want to
stay in buffalo
and i'll tell you what they have really
done a job here they have the best
home batting average in the majors
coming into this game as a team they've
hit the 312 here in this ballpark
and as is usually the case with rowdy
when he gets a hold of one it
is no cheapy 438 feet
the distance of that home run and it's
two to nothing blue chase
mitch moreland struck out in the second
inning that was against merriweather
went the other way that's it pretty well
guriel is turning around and in fact it
gets out of here it's a home run
aguerrio was going back to the warning
track as if he expected to have a chance
to make a play but
mitch moreland just hit his eighth home
run of the season
well that looked like it got a little
gust a win or something
didn't it i didn't think that ball was
going off the back i don't think mullen
thought it was going off the back and it
just kept going and going
and going and it turns into number eight
so run around at second nobody out of
the battle will be rowdy toles who hit
a long home run his first time up and
palette
teles rather hits another one a mile to
right
two at bats and two home runs for rowdy
teles
oh he got a slow curve ball there and
crushed it that's the kind of power and
he's intriguing man when he gets on a
roll there's not a ballpark in the world
that can hold him
yamaguchi on to work in his fourth frame
and he pops it into center field looking
up through the raindrops as randall
griczyk can make the catch
two down and now six in a row set down
by yamaguchi
did he get a piece of it he did not he
did not get it he did not
so yamaguchi strikes out bogarts and
he's gone
four good innings in relief tonight for
the blue jays
and back to the top of the order for
cabin bizio
biggio is oh for three on the night he
hasn't reached base and he's got that
long
streak reaching base in 18 straight
games
hits it hard and how about a 19-game
streak of reaching base
vizie over the base hit and espinal
around the third
the blue jays looking to extend this
lead first and third nobody out
and gretchik shoots the ball the other
way for a base hit
espinal can jog home on this one biggio
to second
and it's five to one here's vladimir
guerrero jr with the bases loaded in one
down
fair ball down the line and already we
can see devers is saying have a look at
that he thought the ball was
foul if it holds up it's a three-run
double for guerrero that clears the
bases and brings a big
smile to bloody space he was smiling as
he went around first base
suddenly it's a big night for vladi it's
8-1 for the blue jays
it's a big night for rowdy teles he's
got a couple of homers and now he's got
a base hit
guerrero is rounding third and there
will be no throws he slides in to make
it nine to
foley will come on and try to close out
this ball game
and another diving stop by biggio two
down
he has two outs here in the ninth inning
and throwing seven pitches
again the o2 and it's popped a mile up
in the sky who's going to find it who's
going to get it reese maguire's got it
in foul territory
gets a hand from his pitcher sean reid
foley and the blue jays bounced back
in convincing fashion here in the second
game of the series buck with a 9-1 win